(lighthearted whistling music)
- There's something
that's not vibing with me
and I don't know what it is.
- The fact that there's no milk in it?
- Yeah, that's probably it.
(both laugh)
- [Man] Mmm, soy creamy.
- [Woman] Soy creamy.
- I wanna clink, should we clink?
- It just tastes like melted Play-Doh.
- When you accidentally
leave something plastic
on the burner in your house
and you start to smell it.
- Tastes bad.
- Really? I'm totally fine with this.
- I could eat this alone.
- I could eat it alone.
- Yeah, just alone by myself in my room.
- I think it's kinda good.
- Well, you're a vegan.
- It tastes like chemicals. It doesn't--
- Yeah, I don't--
- I think I would rather have
milk and diarrhea than chemicals.
- Tastes like a spoonful
of cold, soft almonds.
- Yeah, I'm not a fan of that. (laughs)
- [Man in glasses] Yeah.
- It's funny because I keep
saying I'm not a fan of it
but I keep eating it, so maybe
I am a fan of it. (laughs)
- It's the sad, desperate
smell of a new beginning.
- [Man] Oh, this is awful!
- This tastes exactly like
birthday cake frosting.
- Oh, this is the worst one.
It's got so much sugar
in it for no reason.
- [Woman] Mm-hmm.
- [Man] Oh, it's bad.
- For a second, it just tasted
like a Rice Krispies Treat.
That would've been good.
If it always tasted like
a Rice Krispies Treat,
then I'd be onboard.
But it was just there and gone.
- Oh, god.
- I don't like that at
all. That one's terrible.
- [Woman] No, it tastes like plastic.
- [Man] No, that one's awful.
- Oh, what the (bleep) is that?
- This is like an ice
slushie chemical bath.
- This is an insult to ice cream.
- I don't think anything could save this.
- Why would you eat this?
- By the way, it's not just
vanilla, it's vanilla island.
- Oh. What a (bleep) island.
Well they've put a lot of
care into this packaging,
so they want you to think
that this is good for you,
that this is gonna improve your chakras
and your chi and (bleep).
(woman groans)
- [Man] Oh, it's a daiquiri.
You put a little rum in this
and you can get real drunk, real quick.
- It just, it tastes good, but
also, it tastes like lotion.
- Smells like something
I wanna rub on my skin.
- So if you want a coconut
cream pie in ice cream form--
- [Dark-haired man] Yeah.
- [Man with glasses] Get this.
- [Man] Yup, we did it. We did it.
- It's so good.
- We did it , America.
We made an ice cream that's decent to eat.
- It also smells kinda like poop.
- I feel like it definitely, for me,
tastes better than the
chocolate ice creams
that you get at an ice cream truck.
- This just tastes like I
opened up a cocoa powder box
and just started shoveling
it into my mouth,
which some people might love.
- [Woman] (laughs) Just shove it in there.
- [Man] Yeah, poop's important.
But so is good ice cream.
(breeze blows)
(squeaks)